hey I wanna shoot pool yet why the fancy
red suit mr. pool oh that's because it's
christmas day dopinder and i'm after
someone on my naughty list you're
probably thinking this was a superhero
movie but that guy in the suit just
turned that other guy into a [ __ ]
kabob surprise this is a different kind
of superhero story to tell it right we
gotta take you back before I squeezed
this ass in spandex mr. Wilson you've
recently been diagnosed with terminal
cancer we can fight this what if I told
you we can cure you and give you
abilities most men only dream of I'd say
that you sound like an infomercial but
not a good one like Slap Chop more shake
weighty
I never see you again know that I love
you when I'm finished it mutates its
cells will heal anything but you still
think we're making you a superior we're
making you receivers lame oh come on
you're gonna leave me all alone here
with Jose Canseco whatever they did to
me made me totally indestructible and
completely no unfuckable you you look
like the inside of other people's
[ __ ] I didn't ask to be super and
I'm no hero but when you find out your
worst enemy is after your vest
the time has come to be a [ __ ]
superhero we can't allow this Deadpool I
don't have time for your x-men [ __ ]
Colossus besides nobody's getting hurt
that guy was up there before we got here
when I played a lot of roles damsel in
distress they wanna time to make the
chimi [ __ ] chunga's have you seen
this man
I never say this but don't swallow did I
leave the stove on I mean that's why I
brought her oh no finish your tweet
that's fine just give us a second go get
her tiger so pity the dude who pressures
her into prom sex
so I can do right by someone else and
please don't make the supersuit green or
animated one thing that never survives
this place it's a sense of humor